when being pitched every executive has
this question why am I looking at this
it's a
uh there are I think a couple of uh
shins that may never be asked that you
sort of have to be able to answer with a
pitch
um and that is definitely one of them I
think that's probably the the most
critical first one
it's
and it goes back to a lot of the other
things we've sort of been discussing
it's Executives have very limited time
and they have very specific needs that
they're looking for they need to find
content that's going to fit into very
specific slots or buckets and that's
what they need to know is it going to
fit or is it not and that's really I
think what the core of that question is
why am I looking at this does it work
for us does it fit is it in the price
point can we utilize it can we make it
something into an even bigger
opportunity Etc
but yeah they want to know
how is this serving what we're trying to
do
and should the writer then try to put
themselves in that executive shoes and
question why would they want to look at
this or writers blind to that because
they think that their material is is the
answer I mean should we kind of question
why would this executive meet with me
I think if if you have an opportunity to
meet with
the production company executive
distribution executive anyone in that
World
um I wouldn't question it I would just
sort of utilize it as an opportunity of
how how can my what what what can I do
with my talents and help serve what
you're trying to do in a way uh reason I
say that is not to in any way not be
true to what you want to write or what
you want to create but more
what do I have to do to make my script
work for what you're trying to achieve
here or what can I write to help you
know your company mandate or expectation
of growth you've got to think of like
businesses sort of like systems it's
it's you know it's it's a collection of
small things that they're all trying to
do in order to like just grow grow they
need films they have money to spend and
they have to spend it on movies they
have spent it on movies that are already
completed they have to spend it on
movies that are not yet completed but
are in development so that they can
satisfy their client base so they have
Deep Pockets not
you know not bottomless Pockets but they
do have money to spend
and they're only going to spend it on so
many movies what you need to do is
really figure out okay if you're only
going to spend it on so many movies how
can I make mine be the one that's going
to work and
having a mindset of like zero
concessions and not being a team player
is not going to make that happen but
being able to say here's a couple of
ideas do one of these resonate and then
if it can you know sort of be tweaked
and you know molded a bit and pruned
here and there then it can sort of start
to fit into something that will work not
just for the Distribution Company but
their client who's trying to feed into
an audience or an end user
would you say most of the writers that
reach out to you without representation
they've researched the genres that they
should be pitching you it's not like
it's a total non-match uh it's in truth
it's probably more like 50 50.
um
and
if if I'm if our company is getting I
don't know
50 emails let's say and 25 are just like
I'm I wrote a script about XYZ that has
nothing to do with what you guys do
um you know we'll just politely decline
before we even we'll just we'll just say
no and that's that's assuming you know
we you know it's yeah it's usually just
kind of a it's not going to work for us
we it you know we're not we're not in
that business
um but if it is something that is sort
of dabbling into the world where we work
we'll take a look at it
now taking a look at it doesn't mean
that we're going to buy it or do
business together in the immediate
future but it is an opportunity to sort
of
plant a seed and figure something out
down the road
but yeah I mean we've worked with
writers who've reached out to us blindly
and their initial scripts none of them
were that first thing that got made but
it showed us like okay this person
actually knows how to write the genre
well and then when an opportunity comes
up we have reached out to them and said
like
would you write this and they say yes we
do our deal and they get paid we deliver
the script everyone's happy and we've
done that with a couple writers and then
there's a few others that um
you know we're on good relations with
where we they have the right scripts but
um we just haven't found that project
yet to work on together but I know that
we will because it's just we have
already established that sort of
communication and it's just a matter of
time till we sort of figure out like
okay this will work really well for that
writer because every writer has their
own style too
what is a verifiable audience
um verifiable audience is something that
it's it's a way of describing
a guaranteed viewer of content
um
a legitimate audience of people out
there that you can sort of Bank on or
project upon so what I mean by that is
like if you have a book
um whomever purchased the book would be
a verifiable audience those are people
out there who actually transacted on it
they bought it so they must have had
some kind of interest in it and if you
were to make a movie on that book you
could use that verifiable audience to
sort of project the types of viewers you
would likely have or the types of
outlets you could likely go to it's also
if you think about you know ratings
systems in terms of viewership metrics
that would also be verifiable audience
it's sort of people who
are actually interacting with your
content engaging with it you're able to
sort of look at that audience as a core
Define who they are and be able to sort
of say if we're going to be making a
project like this or in this space who
would our verifiable audience be to
reach out to now in a pitch capacity if
you are trying to sort of bring an idea
to the table to pitch it you would need
to Showcase that your projects have a
verifiable audience this is I think
where it gets a little bit wonky for
people who are sort of new to the
industry because they love to sort of
take outlier projects meaning examples
of movies from the past that were
extremely successful
and you know that we're sort of
not representative of the average but
sort of like those Mega hits that were
like unexpected big hit films or TV
shows or whatever those are the ones
they like to quote a lot but verifiable
audience is actually more of the sort of
boring average it's sort of the
predictable expectation I think the
thing people talk about with Star Wars
for instance the original one way back
in the 70s
um George Lucas said I'm getting my
numbers wrong I haven't thought about
this example in over a decade but it's I
think he was saying at the time an
average movie of that style made about
15 16 million dollars at the box office
so if they could make their movie at
around 10 million they it was going to
be a success obviously like the massive
success of that and what it launched was
never expected by anybody I don't even
think by
George Lucas himself but that kind of
thinking that if we make the move if
there's an audience that repeatedly
watches this kind of content what money
does that generate how do we quantify
that
um where do they watch it and how do we
calculate that out and then if you find
that average you can sort of work your
way backwards too okay well then what
movie do we need to make how much does
it need to cost what kind of cast do we
need to populate it with and that's sort
of the process
how does a beginning writer know their
story has a verifiable audience
I think if you're working with an
original story idea
um it's it's sticking to the sort of
Gold Miner core genres I talk about a
lot
because those are sort of the tried and
tested and proven
you know buckets of programming that are
always in need
so if you are writing a movie in that
space whether it's a tween girl romance
or you know a female driven Thriller
um one of those titles one of those
projects you know you're speaking to a
core group of a core demographic I'll
say of audience that likes and responds
to that it resonates with them now
there's so many granular sort of details
within all that
but that's sort of the beginning point
is if you're sticking to a core genre or
a gold mine genre then at least you know
you're sort of in the right
building so to speak as you get deeper
into it
um I'm not saying write cliches I'm
obviously I'm very against cliches but
it's it's you do need to use you need to
be very true to what that genre is
um so if that's certain types of
character combinations if that's certain
types of story arcs
um that I think is really those are sort
of the the metrics of
am I sort of in the right Zone here and
if you have that down uh I think you're
sort of in the right ballpark so to
speak that's if you're just doing it
totally original work that's and you're
starting from the very beginning of I'm
going to create a story here I'd follow
that mindset of work backwards what does
the industry need what do television
channels need what do VOD platforms need
and what is going to help them grow
audience and sustain it and think about
it at an independent level not at Big
mega million per episode or or you know
multi-million dollar film level I'm
thinking more like a smaller scale low
budget movie under 2 million budget if
you're thinking more at that scale
that's where the real volume is that a
lot of companies work within
that represents the vast majority of
what gets produced every single year on
a global basis and if you're sort of
working in that and you're working in
the core genres you're sort of feeding
into that pipeline of what's needed
can you give me some examples of a
cliche
a couple cliches that uh
uh truth is like you just sort of know
them when you see him it's it's the
expected it's the it's the I mean
there's so many jokes I mean look I work
in Christmas movies like it's so many
jokes about you know
big city girl who uh uh you know just is
having tough time in the city on her own
her perfect life uh doesn't work so she
goes back to her small town you know
these are the that's your cliche and
then of course she reunites with so and
so who she used to know as a kid and
then there's some friction and then like
you know they
hit it off in the end and everything's
perfect and it's a perfect Christmas so
for like a Christmas Romance
um that is sort of the cliche of the
storyline but that structure does work
so you have to find your
differences within that structure and
this is this is actually where the
talent of writing comes in where it's
it's so easy to like poke fun at that
and say anybody can write those things
anybody can write a tween girl romance
film anybody can write a girl in a
Horrors film try it do it like it's it's
harder than it looks and um the amount
of creative meetings I've had on that
storyline on how to make it different
how to make it unique how to maintain an
audience that needs to see that but keep
them engaged so they don't feel like
they're seeing the same thing they've
already seen it's a lot harder than it
looks and there's a lot more involved
development discussions and creative
meetings than you would ever expect
from the very beginning all the way
through pre-production all the way
through the editing process
so it's it's when you're trying to reach
a core verifiable audience it's going
back to Christmas movies because it's an
obvious one
there's hundreds that get made every
single year like you're speaking to an
audience like there's a verifiable
audience and there's metrics from
Lifetime and Hallmark and all of them
that you know they make a certain number
of films every single year
and it goes back to how do you get your
foot in the door well you think about if
they're going to spend all this money
which they're going to I guarantee you
they're already working on their 2024
slates
um how do you augment your work so that
you're the one they spend money on and
it's sort of looking at that and saying
all right that's the tried and tested
expectation that's the genre there's
clearly a verifiable audience for it now
how do I find those subtle differences
that make the structure work uh that
that aren't the same old boring cliche
it's it's it's the classic like the same
thing only different
yeah because I've noticed that a lot of
these films and I think this works it's
somebody returns back to the small
Hometown and they're either met with
open arms or met with resistance but
there's something about that that seems
like it's satisfying to viewers yeah
yeah and look we we've done it the other
way we've had the small town go to the
big city we've had the whole thing take
place in the big city we've had the
whole thing take place in a small town
we've had it be that um it's it's the
lead characters dealing with a loss they
lost a a spouse or a mother or somebody
who is very close to them and so they
are feeling that separation but it's
emotional instead of like physical we uh
we we we're just doing a movie now
um we just wrapped on it and it's about
somebody who returns home but not
because she wants to she's doing it
because she's basically uh at a
Crossroads with her job and she's going
to go home to her small town and
actually
exploit something about her small town
for work to return to the big city her
intention is to go back to the big city
City and she's just utilizing the
opportunity to go there and do something
but of course while she's there she
realizes that she can't do this and
everything's happy in the end but um
it's the intention was very very
different than the same old like so I
guess that motivation of how do you end
up from point A to point B that's it's
those subtle things that sort of make a
script or a story pop and it's a writer
who can deliver unique variations of
that
um
very consistently but like you know
bring something new to the table that
fits the mold every time
that's sort of how it works sure and it
seems like those genres also uh
transcend different age groups as well
they certainly do they certainly do
um
I think Mysteries is sort of a good one
that would fall more into like your
female driven Thriller
but uh Mysteries can can really be you
know you can have your old lady
Mysteries you can have your you know
young fresh audience Mysteries there's
whole series of books that are aimed at
tween readers that are Mysteries so
that's definitely a genre that sort of
satisfies a very wide spectrum but you
can have sub-genres within it that sort
of focus on one demographic at a time
yeah